نبدا حديثنا صباح اليوم عن تطبيق هو
للكثيرين شريان التواصل وحلقه الوصل
بالفعل الواتساب واليوم الدراسات تحضرنا
وتحذركم ايضا انتبهوا الجروبات تشكل خطرا
غير محسوس وربما تؤدي في النهايه للاكتئاب
والقلق وايضا الاضطراب النفسي
اختصاصي علم النفس الاكلينيكي مارك هيكسر
يقول ان هذه المجموعات تزيد من صعوبه
انشاء المجموعات الديناميكيه وتصعب
التفاهم بين الناس على عكس دورها كذلك
فانه على هذه المجموعات
التي عدد
عناصر خياليه
كل هذا ربما يؤدي الى ماذا الى القلق
والانقسام
طبعا تلاميذ كالعاده ج
هينا وايضا طرق للانسحاب الصامت من دون
دراما من جروبات الواتساب
المحادثات المرهقه كثيره عبر مجموعات
الدردشه وهذه بعض النصائح للانسحاب منها
دون احراج من الاخرين اولا يمكن وضع
المحادثات الجماعيه بالوضع الصامت كذلك
يمكن وضع كلمات معينه الرد على الكلام
الكثير القادم من هذه المجموعات يمكن وضع
النوم على العادات فمثلا رغبه الاشخاص
الابتعاد عن الهواتف للراحه قد يكون مبررا
جيدا للهرب من الدردشات الجماعيه دون اي
احراج القول بانك شخص غير مهم في بعض
المحادثات قد يكون مهم جدا لاجل الهرب من
المحادثات الجماعيه فيمكن ان تقول ان هذه
المناقشات ليست بنطاق الصله بحياتك
وبالتالي لا يجب المشاركه بها واخيرا اذا
لم تتمكن من المغادره او الهرب من
المحادثات الجماعيه فيمكن ان تطلب ازالتك
بكل صراحه نظرا لاي سبب تعتقد انه مناسب
لهذا الطلب على كل حال في الاردن قمنا
بتجربه اجتماعيه للكشف عن كم مجموعه
واتساب على هواتف الناس نتابع
هلا انا عندي بالواتساب تقريبا فوق عشره
يعني يمكن عشرين جروب
ومثلا في عندي جروبات تعليميه مثلا زي
كورسات انا باخذها فهي بتكون مسكره اصلا
يعني بس انا بتلقى الرسائل ما برسل وفي زي
جروبات اكيد صاحبات اكيد بتسبب ضغط او
جروب واحد جروب يعني شغل يعني طلعت طاشات
زي هيك ولا مريحه والله عادي يعني شغل بسط
مش
مزعجه لالي يعني في تقريبا عشر جروبات من
ضمنهم العائله اصحاب
بالشغل
في منها الها داعي في منها منسيه يعني من
زمان كانت بس اللي بتستخدمها يعني الشغل
ولا
[موسيقى]
معنا الان في الاستوديو مشاهدينا
الاختصاصي النفسيه الدكتور محمد عبد
البديع اهلا بك دكتور معنا تفضل صباح
الخير صباح الخير صباح السعاده دكتور
جروبات الواتساب يعني انا ربما من الاشخاص
اللي بيزعجوني بشكل كبير يمكن فعلا بسببوا
لي قلق وفي بعض الاحيان اكتئاب وحاولت اني
او شكله بالفطره يعني اتبعت بعض النصائح
بالهروب الصامت خلينا نحكي مبدئيا
شو التاثيرات على على نفسيتنا من جروبات
الواتساب هل هو عددها هل هو كميه التفاعل
اللي بتصير من خلال جروب او ثاني شو
بالضبط يعني انا فوقت نظري ان اهم مشكلات
المتابعه مواقع التواصل عموما يعني هو
الادمان
والتشتت ان الانسان على طول منتظر اشعار
منتظر حد هيكلمه منتظر خبر احيانا ده
بيؤدي الى القلق والتوتر
الانسان اللي بيشغل نفسه بالجروب ايه اللي
حصل ايه متابعه الجروبات بتضيع الوقت ما
يقدرش يركز في شغله وما يقدرش ان هو ينتج
بشكل سليم بنشوف حالات ادمان
وبياثر على انتاجيتهم بالذات الطلبه وصغار
السن او المراهقين
بتؤدي يعني الى ضعف في انتاجيتهم او خلل
في الدراسه طيب دكتور يعني خلينا اليوم
البعض قد يدخل
باكثر من جروب واتساب والحديث يجرب بدل ما
هو مجلس او ديوانيه اصبحت هذا هو مقر
للالتقاء بين الاصحاب زملاء العمل الى
اخره اصحاب الهوايه المشتركه كل هذه
الاخبار وكل هذه المعلومات التي تاتي هل
تؤثر علينا سلبا ام ايجابا البعض يشوفها
متنفس
الاخرين يعني
خير الامور الوسط يعني انا لو بستغل
الموضوع ان انا اعرف اخبار اهلي او
اشاركهم اخباري يطمنوا علي اطمنوا عليهم
اوكي ده استخدامه يعني مفيد اما لو هو
اسيء استخدام الشيء هيؤدي الى اضرار
هيقدرنا نفسيا انه كثره الجروبات ولا لا
اذا كانت كثيره بمعنى ان هي انا بس
البرنامج عندنا يمكن خمس جروبات بس فريق
فريق البرنامج
غير غير الزملاء غير الاصدقاء غير المعارف
غير الاهل كل هذا يعني فوق ال25 الى 30 في
في طرق ان احنا نستخدم التطبيقات دي بشكل
حكيم ان انا مش لازم افتح الاشعارات لكل
الجروبات يعني في جروبات لها اهميه ان انا
لازم اطلع اول باول مفيده لعملي مهمه لان
انا انجز وهكذا لكن في جروبات تانيه يفضل
ان انا حالها على الصامت وما تشغلنيش غير
في الاوقات اللي تناسبني ان انا اقدر
اتابعها او
اذا لازم الامر ان انا اكتشفت ان انا دخلت
انا بخرج
انا باخرج وبصمت يعني انا انا عندي خطه
عاده بعمل بعمله صامت لمده اسبوع وما
بعملش اي تفاعل نهائيا وبعدين هيك بيكون
الوقت متاخر بالليل بعمل ههه الهروب
الكبير نخلع وطبعا
مفيده ولكن هي المشكله في عددها عدد هذه
الكروبات اللي احنا نقحم في بعض الاحيان
فيها هل هناك عدد معين بعد هيك خلص لازم
نبلش ننظف ونخرج من جروبات احنا مش كثير
مهتمين فيها بصراحه ما فيش ابحاث يعني
نقدر نقول ان الرقم ده هو الرقم المناسب
كل واحد فينا كمان بيختلف عن الاخر طبيعه
عمله يعني في واحد طبيعه عمله تستدعي ان
هو يتفاعل مع عدد كبير من الجروبات وفي
واحد لا لكن انا انا اللي بحكم على الجروب
ده هل هو مفيد لي ولا بيجيب لي مشاكل
وبيجيب لي يعني وجع دماغ زي ما بيقولوا
مثلا فالخروج يعني حل ولو ان انا برضو مش
متفق تماما مع فكره الخروج الصامت في كل
الحالات يعني اه ليه هقول لانه ممكن يؤدي
الى دراما يعني ممكن يؤدي لان انا الناس
كلها ليه وتتساءل وخ ليه ومعلش طب اشرح
لنا طب انا انا عملتها مره واحده في رمضان
حتى انه قبل رمضان
حتى لا لا استمر في هذا الجروب لكن اليوم
الدكتور خلينا ناخذها من جانب اخر بانه
هذه المعلومات التي تاتينا البعض اصبح
بالفعل احنا مدمنين واتساب مدمنين مواقع
تواصل اجتماعي اذا تكلمنا عن الواتساب لا
شعوريا اصبح كجزء من حياتنا مثل اليد
والرجل بانه احنا نتطمن على الاخرين هذا
واحد اثنين تاتينا اخبار بعضها مرغوب فيها
وبعضها غصبا عنا طبيعه النفس البشريه كيف
تتعامل مع ذلك نفسيتنا كيف
لازم يكون عندي قدره على التوقع وتحمل
الضغوط يعني الحياه مش دائما كلها اخبار
جيده يعني احيانا بيحصل للاسف اخبار سيئه
عندكم في التحليل النفسي اقدر احط حاجز
بيني وبين ما اتلقاه غصبا عني من اخبار
ولا لا
يعني
ان انت تتقبل الخبر ده مهاره وحاجه لازم
تكون موجوده عند الانسان يعني وارد جدا ان
احنا نتعرض لاخبار سيئه تحمل الاخبار
السيئه دي لازم انما الهروب منها
والاختفاء مستحيل وبرضو مش صحي
على كل حال شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
محمد عبد البديع الاختصاصي نفسي كان معنا
في الاستوديو شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات